these are old people if you mainly watch
Netflix or Amazon Prime or Hulu or
YouTube please stand up $80 billion
spent on commercials in America and
nobody is watching how many people here
four or five years ago maybe three said
the following to themselves or in their
head I'm not getting on Facebook why
would I ever need a Facebook account
that's for the kids raise your hand
don't lie I'm waiting excellent got
about 30 40% just curious who here is
not on Facebook please stand up real
quick it's good for blood circulation
guys let's clap it up for these people
they're fighting the machine good [__]
by the way your horse is waiting for you
outside after this
kyote